tu alors une histoire absolument
hallucinante elle est passagers d'un tgv
reliant paris à nice ont connu une
énorme frayeur cette semaine c'est
bourdin direct qui nous en dit plus
s'est passé mercredi soir aux alentours
de 18h30 tgv paris nice l'incident a eu
lieu à hauteur d' avignon dans le
vaucluse oui un trou de 2 cm dans la
vitre et la munition théoriquement
réservée à la chasse s'est logée dans
l'appuie-tête gros gibier camin la
chasse au gros gibier les chasseurs du
vaucluse explique qu'en théorie à 18h30
ya plus de chasseurs dehors oui et
qu'ils ne sont pas les seuls à posséder
des armes de chasse
c'est une histoire absolument incroyable
heureusement il ya eu deux blessés en
plus c'était une petite fille qui était
assise à cette place là où heureusement
l'été de base sont plus donc ça va voilà
l'avis de retoucher entièrement de
fissurer la balle a laissé un trou
d'environ 2 cm de diamètre
impressionnant quand même franchement
une réaction au jimmy'z cette histoire
oui je pense qu'on est très complaisant
avec les chasseurs il est temps de faire
quelque chose à chaque fois qu'un
événement on considère que c'est un
accident alors la rivalité pas sûr que
ce soit un chasseur est vraiment
simplement ses larmes d'un chasseur
puisque qui peut avoir ce genre de fusil
avec ce type de munition
si les mêmes événements est arrivé en
banlieue alors là on a réussi toute la
droite de l'extrême droite de l'extrême
gauche tout le monde aurait été unanimes
pour condamner ça là c'est peut-être des
chasseurs donc on est un peu trop gentil
il faut qu'on réglemente ca nettement
plus à acheter que c'est que des haltes
et n'hésitez pas à réagir à cette
histoire absolument incroyable qui
heureusement ne s'est pas terminée dans
un drame parce que ça aurait vraiment pu
se terminer par un drame